[Music]
i set the world record in february 2019
at that time i had 20 139 games
the passion never stopped and right now
i stand around 22
840 games roughly
hi my name is antonio romero montero i
hold the guinness world record for the
largest video game collection in the
world
it all started when i was a young kid my
passion for video games amount of time
and hours i spent playing
i couldn't even start describing that
and you know as i got older
the passion
was always there grew
and
just kept simmering
when i finally started working and
had started the opportunity then to
start buying more video games
it started with simply trying to buy
some of the games that i played as a
child one of the things i love about
games is actually some of the fantasy
side
some of the fiction
some of the imagination that comes with
the art style
you know one way or another it's become
a part away of how i think how i act
and it's driven into parts of my being
in essence
so
i get to share also one of the rarest
playstation 4 games in the world
there's only 84 known copies of this
game
and it was for sale for a very very
limited amount of time
and uh
definitely comes with some backstory and
some uh interesting components to how
this was issued and published
but for me one of the most hilarious
part is
the title and the theme of the game
making it one of the rarest is a game
called poopslinger
and i guess you can all imagine what the
theme of the game is
[Music]
this is one of the rarest playstation
4's in the in the world
so this is a limited edition
hitman playstation console
there's only one manufactured in the
entire world
and it was originally put up as a raffle
reward promotional item
for when
the hitman game came out on playstation
4. and it's shaped as the suitcase of
the main protagonist of the game hitman
but it's a fully functional playstation
system
and
definitely pretty cool
so the continuation of my collection
actually has nothing to do with the
record um i quite openly
anybody that wants to challenge it and
take the record it's there for the
taking okay
really the reason i keep on my
collection is just for the continued
passion and enjoyment i do play quite a
few games still
in the little spare time that i find to
play
but it's just an enjoyment it's the
challenge that comes with the collecting
side it's
seeing titles that you've never seen
before finding some rare stuff
and nowadays i'm starting to play a
little bit more with collecting items
from japan as well which is pretty cool
because you get to see
how they looked in japan versus how they
look in the u.s
and some of the art contrasts of some of
the minor details which are pretty
entertaining you know it's been fun that
that's the biggest part about it it's
fun okay
it's fun to go out and find
titles that you've played and say
and reminisce about those experiences
and then
slowly building up and achieving those
collections it's just a fulfilling
component that i've enjoyed
and i think you know in the end every
one of us carries a certain passion
certain hobby something that we do to
enjoy ourselves
and this is what i've chosen to do it's
just the experience with the games the
passion
the storytelling that comes with it the
art style
and all the memories that i relive every
time i get to see these games play them
and enjoy them with my family nowadays
[Music]
you